it's an honor for me to be here with you
today
um together we are making a difference
[Applause]
i am i come from sweden and back back
there
it's almost the same problem as here as
everywhere
that nothing is being done to to stop
the climate and ecological crisis
despite all the beautiful words and
promises
and we are now facing in
existential crisis the climate crisis
and ecological crisis
which have never been treated as crisis
before
they have been ignored for decades
and for way too long the politicians and
the people in power
have gotten away with not doing anything
at all
to fight the climate crisis and the
ecological crisis
but we will make sure that they will not
get away with it any longer
humanity is now standing at a crossroads
we must now decide which path we want to
take
how do we want the future living
conditions for all species to be like
we have gathered here today and on many
other places around london
and across the world too we have
gathered today because
we have chosen which path we want to
take and now we are waiting for the
others to follow our example
we are the ones making a difference we
the people in this extinction rebellion
and the children school striking for the
climate we are the ones making a
difference
it shouldn't be like that but since no
one else is doing anything
we will have to do so
and we will never stop fighting we will
never stop fighting for this planet
and for ourselves our futures and for
the futures of our children and
grandchildren
thank you